What did they say there would be no more candidates
deluded?
I have very good news for you,
what good,
excellent news
for Nuevo León,
for Mexico and especially for young people
that we are the majority in this country.
The deluded of the old politics
believed that we had run out of candidates,
that hitting Samuel
millions of young people would be left without this fresh option.
and the future,
because they are wrong
because Samuel
was the pre-candidate,
but there are millions of us in this team,
in this collectivity
that we want something new,
so today I want to tell you
that I deliver the Estafeta
here to my compadre who was the campaign coordinator,
Jorge Álvarez Maynes,
then I want to tell you that we have a candidate
very good,
pre-candidate
and is the most orange and yellow of all,
because it is the one that represents the oldest and most
to this great platform
citizen movement.
It will be a great honor for me to have this Relay,
working alongside Mariana here in Monterrey,
give this city the government it deserves,
as our friend Luis Donaldo Colosio has done,
and that millions of young people know
that does not happen to us,
who did not get away with it,
that the PRI and bread are more fried
than eggs,
that we had breakfast with the ha ha ha machaca
and we are going to show Mexico and the old politics
who have messed with the wrong generation,
so we wish you the best.
Take off Maine,
Uh, yes,
with everything goes again
and without Telepronter